pleno del Congreso de la república
El Congreso de Perú rechazó debatir una
moción de destitución contra la
presidenta Dina boluarte que fue
presentada por legisladores de izquierda
que la vinculan con decenas de muertes
en las protestas en su contra he votado
por la vacancia porque de los más de 60
muertos 49 han fallecido por proyectiles
armas de fuego que vienen de
instituciones del estado la propuesta
recibió 37 votos a favor 64 en contra y
diez abstenciones y ahora será archivada
en consecuencia no ha sido admitida la
moción de orden del día del pedido de
vacancia para la presidencia de la
república Y pasa al archivo las
manifestaciones que paralizaron el país
por varios meses comenzaron en diciembre
tras la destitución y detención del
presidente Pedro Castillo quien intentó
disolver el congreso y gobernar a través
de decreto Castillo pidió hoy la
intervención de Naciones Unidas para
encontrar justicia en su caso Porque
creo importante
decirle a esta sala que soy un preso
político porque el fondo de este
episodio tiene un interés político
concluyó
haciendo un llamado
y pidiendo la intervención de los
organismos de derechos humanos de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas Ya
que en el Perú ni mi pueblo ni yo
yo encontramos justicia castillo y
boluarte también son investigados por la
fiscalía por la presunta financiación
ilegal del partido Perú libre en las
elecciones generales de 2021 la antigua
fórmula presidencial ahora dividida
niega las acusaciones y cree que los
expedientes en su contra son una
persecución política